So now you've seen a pretty extensive
tour of the features offered by
Android Wear.
We explained how wearable APKs
are distributed by the Play store.
You also learned how an Android Wear
device is basically a complete Android
implementation supporting the same APIs
as what you're already familiar with.
We have added data items and messages to
allow you to easily send data between
devices without having to implement
your own network communications.
Simplifying the development
of wearable apps.
Wearable devices also have different
displays than previously available.
So, we learned how to support round and
scroll outs.
And also, how to take advantage of
Android Wear's Always on Display feature
to provide easily glanceable
information at any time.
Now you know all the important
information necessary
to implement a complete
Android Wear app.
>From designing the initial
layout to packaging it up and
distributing it to your users.